la abstención en la segunda vuelta de la
elección presidencial se acercará a
28% es una información que acabamos de
recibir una estimación de ipsos otra
seria para france24 ese 28% es superior
en 26 puntos a la tasa de abstención de
la segunda vuelta de 2017 que fue de
25,4 por ciento es un dato importante
porque dados los resultados de la
primera vuelta se espera una tasa récord
de abstención en sentido general la
jornada transcurre sin incidentes los
franceses votan en calma como aquí en el
distrito 20 de parís en el noreste de la
ciudad luz también votaron ambos
candidatos marín le pen y emanuel macaco
lo hicieron en el norte del país en el
departamento de paso de calle una región
estratégica para ambos los aspirantes a
la presidencia regresan a parís hoy
mismo para esperar el resultado un
resultado preliminar que se conocerá
cerca de las 8 de la noche y para lo
cual la alcaldía parisina ha preparado
un dispositivo de seguridad excepcional